it's got to the point now where it looks
like i'm toting for work at disney's
front door oh i see it give me the
opening i see what you're saying
yeah but i of course i'd be happy to do
it um did you steal a lightsaber yes you
did that the first time
and where is that lightsaber now you
don't know
hey everybody it's charlie you guys
probably just saw the awesome news
they confirm that ewan mcgregor is
coming back
to do a star wars obi-wan kenobi series
for disney plus
so we'll break all the details down to
my top 10 predictions if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos
i will be doing episode videos for the
mandalorian when it premieres later this
year too
so i will talk about the actual schedule
for the disney plus star wars series
because there are a couple of those that
they've already announced and started
producing
but we had heard ewan mcgregor talk
about coming back as obi-wan for a long
time
they had been rumored to be doing a star
wars obi-wan movie
right up until the solo movie bond and
they completely changed their plans for
how they were doing the star wars movies
because they talked about doing a boba
fett movie but then when they canceled
those plans they basically turned that
into the mandalorian tv series and now
the obi-wan movie
is basically becoming the obi-wan disney
plus series
a lot of this we already know about so
top 10 predictions and details
so number 10 they'll do six to eight
episodes with a chance for multiple
seasons
it's easier for major film actors to do
television when it's only a half a
season when they do a handful of
episodes
instead of doing the normal 22 23
episode seasons that tie them up for
almost the whole year
and right now ewan mcgregor is very
active that's how we get all these clips
of him talking about coming back as
obi-wan because every year he'll release
a new movie
and every time he'll go on talk shows
and people will ask him are you coming
back to play obi-wan again you know yeah
only obi-wan was that something that you
would be interested in that's a good
title only
only obi yeah and he's been pretty coy
but i think the idea was
is that a couple years ago they talked
to him about officially doing an obi-wan
movie then when plans fell through for
that they went back to him and said okay
we kind of like to do this as a disney
plus series which he obviously said yes
to because they're confirming it now
but number nine no-brainer here the
series will most likely take place
during that time period that the obi-wan
movie
would have covered a few years after he
took luke skywalker to tatooine and
settled down in his old ben kenobi
persona
but that was happening 16 years prior to
the beginning of a new hope so you have
to think about the timeline here
he had a lot of adventures during that
period he didn't stay on tatooine every
minute of every day for those entire 16
years
so that's the stuff that they'll cover
on the tv series and even though the han
solo movie completely bombed hard with
fans and critics
there was a very clear teaser at the end
of that they were trying to set
something up for future obi-wan movie
stuff
with the returned darth maul who had
taken over the crimson dawn criminal
empire and was sort of a boss of bosses
in his corner of the galaxy
bring the ship and come to me on
dathomir
and you and i will then decide what to
do about the traitor
beckett and his accomplices
i am sure that ray park would love to
come back and play more live-action
darth maul
or even if that doesn't work out and
they want to go younger and use sam
witwer as
live-action darth maul if you're not a
long-time star wars animated series fan
sam whitword did the voice for maul
during star wars clone wars animated
series in the star wars rebels series
so number eight we should just say that
darth maul should be the main villain of
this series
but here's the thing star wars rebels
takes place about five years before a
new hope
in the darth maul post credit scene on
the star wars solo movie was happening
about
10 years before a new hope so they have
a solid five years of untouched
territory when darth maul is rising to
power in the criminal syndicates and he
hasn't had his last
standoff rematch with obi-wan kenobi
during star wars rebels
because that's basically the end of
darth maul's timeline is during star
wars rebels that's when he finally
killed him
so if they don't want to break the
cannon because technically star wars
rebels and clone wars are canon to all
the films all they have to do is just
make sure that obi-wan doesn't kill
darth maul before he's supposed to quote
unquote but i'm totally fine with that
as long as they have
at least a couple epic lightsaber
battles seven the tone of the series is
probably going to be a little high
plains drifter space western just like
the mandalorian
it's just that obi-wan is less of a
neutral protagonist you know
exactly what he would and he wouldn't do
how he would act in situations
the mandalorian character is a bounty
hunter and he's more of a scoundrel when
you meet him for the first time
so six what's the actual arc of the
series going to be
early prediction here some of this is
based on what the planned plot of the
obi-wan movie was going to be
so obi-wan destabilizing crimson dawn in
darth maul's criminal empire
leaving him in ruins in pieces just like
he left him in pieces after phantom
menace
usually big series like this have big
goals and small goals like obi-wan
destroying a criminal empire is a really
big deal
but while that's going on he needs to be
trying to save someone that he cares
about he needs to have some personal
stakes in it that don't involve
luke skywalker because they can't really
do a whole lot with luke skywalker
during this period i don't think that
they want to touch the holy trinity of
star wars characters too much on these
tv series
but there have been rumors about them
doing a young leia tv series like millie
bobby brown
playing a very young version of leia
that would be a big disney plus series
they killed off obi-wan's love interest
sateen during clone wars but so much of
his life during this period between
movies is unknown it's possible they
could introduce a new one or someone
that he cares about
but as far as we know there's still no
quote-unquote daughter
of obi-wan even though there's still
plenty of theories going on in the star
wars movies right now
five talking about other villains they
already also killed off asaji ventress
during clone wars so they can't bring
her back either
but there's still all kinds of minor
dark side adepts and sith artifacts they
can use in the story to invoke a lot
more
jedi aspects of the mythology anytime
you tell a big star wars story movie or
tv show there's always the force based
lore
and then there's the more political
military side of things like the empire
or the criminal underworld
i'm expecting the series to be more of a
criminal underworld story with
jedi stuff in it but the other really
cool thing that he was doing during this
time you guys will remember
was studying in how to become a force
ghost qui-gon jinn
spent most of this period teaching him
how to do it but number four talk about
the other series the obi-wan series
can cross over with some of the other
live-action star wars series set during
this period
but not the mandalorian the mandalorian
is the one that's coming first but
that's set five years after return of
the jedi so that's
way long time in the future after what
we would see during the obi-wan series
the one that we know that's happening
right around this time though is the
star wars rogue one prequel series
so this sort of bump up against each
other you could cross those series over
but obi-wan kenobi didn't really get
involved with the rebellion
until a new hope when he was being
called back into action by leia
years ago you fought with my father in
the clone wars meaning that she probably
had not met him as an adult and leia was
a core part of the birth of the
rebellion so she was around that all the
time
if he'd have been around for that too
they would have already crossed paths
before the events of new hope
number three because obi-wan was trying
to stay off the empire's radar during
this period i'm not expecting to see a
ton of huge imperial characters like
grand moff tarkin or the bigger generals
that we know were still alive during
this period
if he would have ever gotten in a big
fight with imperial officers and storm
troopers they would have reported it and
eventually darth vader and the emperor
would have heard rumblings about an old
jedi living on tatooine
eventually they would have found out
about luke skywalker and tried to turn
him
before the events of a new hope or
killed him if he wouldn't come over to
the dark side
so most of the characters during the ob1
series probably going to be a mixture of
brand new people we've never seen before
in a couple of old favorites just darth
maul being the biggest one
number two since they made the series
official now we all thought it was gonna
happen for a long time but they just
made it official
that means they probably won't start
shooting it till next year which means
we probably won't actually see episodes
till 2021
but that's not a huge deal the whole
idea of the star wars content now is
that they're taking a break from the
movies for at least two to three years
after
episode nine drops this christmas and
then filling that gap with the big
budget tv series
right now we know about three confirmed
ones in a possible fourth one
the mandalorian is launching in november
i will do episode videos for that
they're probably gonna drop the first
official trailer next week at d23
they'll probably post it online so i'll
do a breakdown of that when that does
drop
there's the rogue one prequel show which
is probably gonna premiere sometime
next year they've already confirmed a
lot of that cast from the movie is
coming back
now we have the obi-wan series and then
there's a rumored fourth one that we
don't know about yet
i always thought that they would try to
do a young leia series but i think that
they were trying to give some time
since carrie fisher passed away so i'm
not expecting that to happen anytime
soon
but the idea with these disney star wars
series in the marvel series
is that there'll be a couple of them
every single year eventually
we know they're doing the mandalorian
season 2 so some of these star wars
series will get second seasons which i
don't think is the case with the marvel
ones but
i'll just do new breakdown videos as we
get more details about which
disney plus star wars shows they're
gonna do but they could do stuff from
all over the timeline
including all the way back to knights of
the old republic in number one big
prediction here i really hope
for an occasional appearance from liam
neeson as qui-gon jinn force ghost
yoda in maybe an occasional darth vader
live-action appearance
here's the thing it's a lot easier to
explain qui-gon jinn showing up to teach
obi-wan how to become a force ghost
because we knew that was happening
during this period
but when darth vader and obi-wan fought
each other during a new hope
the implication based on their dialogue
was that they had not faced each other
directly in combat since the battle on
mustafar in episode three
but as long as they're not standing
right next to each other it'd probably
be fine
an interesting thing too is that darth
vader and the emperor would probably
know
what darth maul was doing with crimson
dawn during this period too
even though they themselves were not
pursuing him but everybody post your
reactions and all your predictions for
this
obi-wan kenobi star wars series i think
it's going to be awesome i love ewan
mcgregor he's a great actor
like i said d23 is going to be happening
next week we'll probably get a trailer
for the mandalorian so there'll be a lot
of star wars news happening around that
time
while you wait for everything click here
to learn about the avengers endgame
loki spin-off series that's coming to
disney plus and click here for my video
from the boys season 1 ending on amazon
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys
tonight